j'accueille maintenant gaspard proust
pour elle est pas belle la vie
[Musique]
alors ça y est c'est arrivé rené coty a
pété un câble il ya six mois il se
prenait pour mitterrand maintenant il se
prend pour le maréchal rommel
alors un type de la manif de dimanche
passé l'a comparé à hitler bon c'est pas
c'est pas complètement faux e mails
c'est quoi c'est une pologne déshydraté
alors historiquement la seule expédition
de l'armée française dans le désert
c'était napoléon vias qu'au total
finalement alors voir hollande réussir
là où napoléon a échoué c'est à peu près
aussi probable que découvrir ben laden
planqué dans la grotte de lourdes
alors il a appelé l'opération militaire
l'opération serval alors c'est un félin
c'est un petit félin qui est la
particularité de pisser 30 fois en une
heure pour marquer son territoire
comme quoi d'être intronisé sous la
pluie ça vous marque une présidence
alors évidemment branle bas de combat le
ministre de la défense annonce des raids
aériens sur le mali ah bon et un truc à
bombarder la base
je ne sais pas tu montre une photo du
mali avant les bombardements un général
de la deuxième guerre mondiale ils te
répondent c'est un bon travail quoi
passer toute la démesure française est
là quoi poursuivre des pick-up avec des
mirage et des rafales
alors de nombreux français se posent des
questions la première est ce que c'est
stratégique d'envoyer des hommes au mali
ah bah évidemment le mali c'est
stratégique reste on peut pas faire
partie des grandes puissances mondiales
si on contrôle pas de la production de
manioc et de patates douces et c'est
évident
or la france a envoyé 1700 hommes est-ce
que c'est suffisant faisons un calcul
rapide sachant qu'il faut une équipe de
32 policiers du raid pour faire sortir
de sa salle de bains à un type armé de
deux colts
convient en foot il pour affronter 6000
djihadistes frottant à l'air libre alors
je fais le calcul six mille fois trop
oms a fait 180 mille hommes au mali
combien la france on at elle envoyé
bon alors l'autre question c'est combien
de temps va durer l'opération continuons
les calculs sachant qu'il a fallu trente
heures aux policiers du raid pour
déloger momo de son hammam privatif
pour 6000 hommes cela fait donc trente
heures fois 6000 hommes ce qui nous
donne deux cent quarante mille jours
donc 657 en
hollande où l'optimisme
alors bon attention on n'est pas les
seuls à on a des renforts les belges
envoie 75 soldats mais pas au front on
se sait pas c'est pour le soutien moral
je vois le truc tu vois ils viendront
avec des banderoles allez les bleus
est bon en face les mecs cd sérieux quoi
c'est ils disent qu'ils vont taper le
coeur de la france on va encore mal
dormir à tulle
façon on s'y prend très mal avec les
islamistes pour des fanatiques faut
envoyer des fanatiques sais pas ce qu'il
leur faudrait c'est pas des légionnaires
mais les mecs de civitas
en tout cas l'otage occidental à la cote
pour les islamistes les otages
catholique se trouve peut-être de
religion mais en termes de valeur
marchande c'est du bien de luxe au sahel
otage occidental c'est comme
l'immobilier à paris ceux des mots de
passe et valeurs sûres
bon évidemment une guerre c'est aussi
des familles déchirées et moi j'ai une
pensée émue pour toutes les femmes des
djihadistes rester derrière la ligne de
front se doit pas être évident être une
femme de djihadistes c'est la nana qui
reçoit une lettre de son mec mon amour
je t'aime je pense à toi ps pourquoi tu
lis ces mots un pur chienne
sont en ce moment la france là un truc
avec les pays en ali quoi somme a dit
mme alifa je serai l'italie je me
méfierais un peu
alors on dit que l'opération est un
fiasco en somalie balle c'est faux c'est
à dire plus d'otages français s'est
enfin plus vivant
réussite réussi toute façon au fond moi
force de faire ces bêtises hollande au
mali mamadou quoi c
il en faut pour tout le monde
société alors la semaine passée a eu
cette manif je ne sais plus très bien
contre pour jobs alors bertrand delanoë
réclament 100 mille euros pour les
dégâts je suppose que lors de la
prochaine manifestation pro mariage gay
et demanderont les numéros de téléphone
des manifestants
[Applaudissements]
moi j'ai été extrêmement choqué par
certains slogans vraiment zéro maman
c'est déprimant on voit qu'ils
connaissent pas ma mère
alors ils couinent parce qu'ils sont pas
entendus ça c'est vraiment des bleus en
france et encore des naïfs qui pensent
qu'on peut bloquer le pays sans bosser à
la sncf
non tu m'étonnes que hollande y résiste
à la pression de la rue dur c'est pas
très dur de résister à une manif de
droite une manif de gauche s'ils sont
pas entendus il bloque les métros là les
gens y vont bloquer quoi ils vont
bloquer quoi l'accès à la maison du
chocolat et un petit bateau c'est sa
façon on mélange tout entre le mariage
l'adoption la pma toute façon je me pose
moi je me suis demandé à quoi est-ce
qu'on reconnaît un enfant né sous pma et
c'est le mec qui crie maman quand ils
voient une pipette
et qui fait une dépression quand il fait
des tp de chimie là il peut plus passer
bon moi personnellement moi j'aimerais
vraiment être un enfant adopté qu'à en
couchant avec des fans 45 ans j'aurais
au moins l'espoir que l'une d'entre
elles soit ma mère
en a pour tous les goûts
façon moins il commence à me saouler
avec leur histoire de mariage toi même
si c'est mais légitime c'est vraiment
c'est à dire la réforme c'est moi je
suis sûr que le rêve de rimbaud et
verlaine c'était de s'acheter un lob
dans le marais et de louer le ventre de
george sand pour y faire fructifier
leurs noms de l'art celte non plus
il ya des évidences comme ça ça saute
aux yeux c'est implacable après je
comprends que l'église soit contre le
mariage gay c'est normal c'est ce qui
gêne l'église c'est pas l'amour entre
deux hommes mais c'est que vu les
orifices concernés dans un couple homo
il est impossible de rester vierge
jusqu'au mariage
[Applaudissements]
reproché à l'église d'être contraintes
sont naïves quand je veux dire il joua
bien moi benoît 16 qui va bouger son
dogme pour faire plaisir à la gay pride
faut franchement faut se réveiller quoi
benoît 16 qui est allé jusqu'à citer le
grand rabbin bernheim pour appuyer ses
propos c'est étonnant c'est tendance à
c'est peut-être la première fois qu'un
pape cite un juif en dehors d'une
préfecture de police
économie alors la période des soldes
continuent chez renault on va licencier
sept mille cinq cents ouvriers
franchement quand on voit la gueule de
leur voiture ferait mieux de licencier
les mecs qui les dessine
[Applaudissements]
chaque fois que je vois une renault je
me dis que les types qui les dessine
sont des anciens de chez playmobil
façon les futurs concessionnaires se
sera joué club à mon avis dans combien
de temps le sport armstrong s'est dopé
je vois vraiment pas où est le problème
je dire si tout le monde se dope à la
fin c'est quand même le meilleur qui
gagne
fait divers alors c'est un mec qui reste
est mort pendant 36 heures voire les
toilettes d'un hôpital sans être
découvert alors peut-être que la lutte
contre les maladies nosocomiales ça
serait déjà de faire venir une femme de
ménage plus d'une fois par semaine
sinon bonne nouvelle marseille capitale
européenne de la culture
c'est la vanne
alors est pas belle la vie et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater le in a l'habitude
abonnez vous il mettait un peu de bleu